Welcome, everybody, we are we're getting close,
very, very close to the election, and we predicted
this time it could happen.
You don't have to be a master of statistics
or mathematics to look at the corona virus
numbers and understand that we could be easily
heading towards hundred thousand cases a day
within several weeks.
And when Dr. Foushee said it months ago, when
Foushee said, if we don't do X, Y and Z, we
could be looking at 100000 American corona
virus cases per day in the fall.
Some people said he sounded crazy.
Some people said it made no sense.
Some people said, oh, down, Fouche.
She wants everything closed forever.
But indeed, when you look at the numbers,
it appears that we are going in a direction
where part of the country is pretending as
though the pandemic is over.
They're behaving as though it's over.
But we are set seeing new record numbers going
back several months in terms of cases.
Of course, you have people saying, well, cases
are up, but deaths aren't up.
And that is true sort of so far, although
if you look at the seven day average, we now
are seeing an uptick in the number of deaths.
So let's sort of look at everything from the
beginning.
Reset the pandemic so we can all get on the
same page.
What I am going to put on the screen for you
here, and I will describe it if you're just
listening, is a chart of U.S. cases per day
dating all the way back to February.
And then the blue line that you see, that's
the seven day moving average, which shows
us the general week to week direction of cases.
Are they generally going up or down?
So you'll see that in mid-April we peaked
with about 32000 cases a day.
Health measures were able to reduce that down
to about 20000 cases a day in late May.
But then things started opening up.
And Dr. Foushee said, you know, we're not
really at the place where we can do this.
We're only down to 20000 cases a day.
We need to be down at least a 10000 a day
with at least a million tests a day to reopen.
People didn't listen, so we got another spike
and we went back up not to 32000 cases a day,
but all the way up to 70000 cases a day in
mid-July.
And then again, with people being mostly outdoors
and lots of places taking more serious measures.
We were able to get back down to 35000 cases
a day in early September.
So the first time after a spike, we got down
to 20 K.
The next spike was bigger and we only got
down to 35 K, and then we reopened more stuff.
Movie theaters, casinos.
And now in the last few days, we've had some
of the worst days, including 72000 cases in
one day on Friday.
And when you look at the trend line now, you
see that we are headed up and potentially
to 100000 cases in a single day within a few
weeks.
Now, there are folks who are going to say,
but but.
But, but, David.
Deaths aren't going up.
Deaths lag cases at by at least two to three
weeks.
We now are better at treating this and better
at keeping people alive longer.
So it would extend that lag time even a little
bit more.
But if you look at the trend line on deaths,
you will see that after a seven week decline
in the death trend line, it leveled out in
early September.
And in the last few days, there's a small,
but it is there blip upwards on deaths.
And the expectation is that it will continue
to climb.
Now, I am the first to admit that there is
some good news here, which is that we are
better at treating this now than we were six
months ago.
I expect that given X number of cases today
versus X number of cases six months ago, fewer
people would die today.
Now in part, that's because younger people
on average are getting the disease right now.
In part, it's because you have very few, if
any, hospitals overwhelmed right now.
And in part, it's because we have better treatment
protocol and some medications that are helping
some of the sickest patients as soon as hospitals
get overwhelmed.
If it happens, which they might, as we enter
flu season, that could change.
And you could see the rate of death go up
as well.
Hopefully it won't.
Now, similar things are happening in other
countries.
You remember Italy was one of the early hot
spots brutally hit.
They got it under control.
They have now had their worst week in the
entire pandemic in terms of cases in the last
week.
They had a record almost 12000 cases yesterday.
So Italy is spiking.
One other example, France, which had it very
much under control, also with record spikes
over the last 10 days.
Much worse than what they had in March and
April.
And remember, Italy and Europe in general
have not yet had a second spike.
If you look at our numbers, we had the April
spike and the July spike.
And now we're seeing spike number three.
Italy, France, European countries avoided
that second spike all summer.
We may be heading to something unconscionably
worse than what Europe is heading towards.
And meanwhile, Donald, Donald Trump continues
to hold huge rallies.
So we'll talk on the bonus show later this
week about what fall and winter might look
like individually.
I've been reading some medical recommendations
about Thanksgiving and sort of dealing with
some realities there.
Let me know what you are planning for, whether
you're in the United States or not for the
next four months, essentially.
And we'll discuss that on an upcoming bonus
show.